The first thing I'll say is I challenged
that there might be a founder here in
the audience that's going to do
something big.
Um,
it's like the birthday paradox,
right?
Like there's absolutely the chance that
someone in this room here today will be
the CEO,
cto,
founder of like one of the world's most
changing companies in the next 10 years.
He live in a really special place where
people get to work on ideas where
failure is tolerated.
If you travel overseas to other places,
there's a reason why silicon valley is
so different and it's because failure is
tolerated.
I realized that I loved doing lots of
different stuff.
It's not that I loved technology,
it was that I loved doing lots of
different stuff.
So I went to boarding school and I was
the guy hanging a,
uh,
an antenna outside of my dorm room
window to do a pirate radio station.
I was designing flyers for dances.
I was deejaying,
like I just love doing a lot of
different things.
And when I read the required reading in
school,
our junior year was this book called the
new new thing,
kind of the Netscape Saga,
right?
Um,
I read that and I said to myself like,
this feels like an area of the world I
can come to and be myself and do lots of
different things and see what sticks,
a little schizophrenic and how I treat
different ideas and go from thing to
thing.
But that's kind of the ethos of an
entrepreneur to teach myself ruby on
rails.
And I was like,
this is going to be a really awesome
skill.
So I learned that,
learned about databases and learned
enough to be dangerous.
And this is one of the lessons in
entrepreneurship is that like,
you don't have to be the best,
but you have to be dangerous.
You have to learn just enough to be
dangerous to build an idea,
concept it and show it to the world.
And then it turns out there are lots of
other people including all 170 employees
that work at instagram who are much
better at doing all that stuff than I
am.
But you'd need to find people who can be
drawn to the idea that you build and
then they ended up taking it and make an
even better.
I think everyone's experience is
different.
Everyone in this room has to take the
idea that there is a perfect next move
and throw it out the window.
There's no perfect.
Next move.
I had the privilege of going to a Marine
base once and talking to marines about
how they plan their next move.
There's this phrase called bias towards
action.
The idea that you can spend all of your
time thinking about what the perfect
next move is trying to plan.
Am I going to work at Google?
Am I going to work at Microsoft?
Like which one Mckinsey or Bain,
like the next perfect move and spending
a tremendous amount of time trying to
figure that out.
The marine say you can spend all the
time you want,
but by the time you figured it out,
you're dead.
So like sometimes you need to make a
tradeoff of what is the action I can
take with the appropriate amount of
information and risk to move because
moving and progress is what gets us to
the next step by moving and learning.
It all adds up.
That summation of your experience over
the last 10 years is what makes you into
the thing tomorrow that will be
successful.
All the other jobs that I had offered,
there were like two or three,
a couple at a startup,
one at Microsoft and Google.
I took the lowest salary of anyone,
any of the offers that I had because I
wanted to work in a specific job at
google.
I didn't care what job it was actually.
I just cared that it was at Google and I
would surround myself by amazing people.
That was the first lesson that I learned
is like go to where the people are short
term longterm tradeoffs.
Just go to where the people are.
Being at Google and going to Corp Dev
was an interesting move because I was
like,
I want to be nurse startups again.
I learned a lot about startups in
school,
but I want to be back in the startup
world and then 2008 happened and I'm not
sure how many people remember 2008 in
this room.
The economy kind of went to crap.
I remember looking at my boss and being
like,
okay,
so like,
can we buy this company is like,
nope,
can we buy this company note one of
them,
and I won't even name the name,
but it was a really interesting company.
Ended up doing really well.
I wish we had purchased it,
but the thing is he was like,
we're actually not going to do many
deals now.
You should probably just go golfing and
for like a 20 something year old
thinking to themselves like I want to
make a difference in the world and your
boss is telling you to go golfing.
Like maybe I should just leave.
So I did and I actually,
there's a chapter in between Google and
Bourbon that not many people know about,
but I ended up joining a startup of some
ex Google folks called nextstop.
Hugely transformational for me because
it's where I cut my teeth,
learning to program,
learning to build a site and everything
I learned in that year at next stop
before starting bourbon was actually
like,
it made me ready to go do bourbon.
So again,
every move you think needs to be
perfect.
It turns out just like surround yourself
by great people where you can learn the
most and great things will happen.
But I didn't go golfing and that's rule
number two.
I never know I will be able to survive
for 20 years.
So I call myself like a blind man.
Riding on the back of a blind tiger for
20 years.
Survived to today,
Stu surviving that.
We want to make this company lost 102
years.
So we finished only 16 years.
There are 86 years ago.
You started in 1999 because in China
everybody wanted to be make company for
last 100 years that this become a
slogan.
Nobody take it too seriously.
So if you want,
if you want to give,
you know,
the KPI to your people should be very
specific and people know it's a serious
100,
two years that we were born in 1999.
Alibaba,
so will last a century.
We had a one year and this central one
to have a winder years,
next century,
one year,
100,
two crossroads centers.
So very specific.
So we're in our company.
We never talked to your succeed,
successful or not because we think
they're 86 years,
next 86 years.
There are many chance that failed.
So that's why we say don't talk about
your successful.
Eighty six years later we'll talk about
it and this is something we know how to
make this thing happen.
So I think generally I'm a positive,
but nectar two or three years maybe have
problems.
People say,
well anticorruption this,
but think about anticorruption and rule
by law is laying a great foundation for
the market.
Common economy.
You don't want to go to business by
bribery.
You don't want to have an unfair
environment.
The market Kami is by rule by law and
market economy is very clear,
transparent and fair and I think this
year does here bad,
but this is why we need
entrepreneurship.
This is why we need the business to
drive the economy.
So I'm the positive and people when
people worry,
I'm happy when people too happy.
I started worrying because.
And I don't worry about the things the
president is worried about,
worry about the things that nobody worry
about and this is the opportunity.
So I'm positive because I'm not,
I'm not positive,
but I'm not stupid.
I know you have a problems,
but you have to solve the problems.
They by little and um,
that's it.
Play one game a little bit with me for
just a minute.
I'd like for the moment
to have you have you pretend I've made
you a great offer and I've told you that
you could pick any one of your
classmates and you now know each other
probably pretty well after being here
for awhile.
You can take 24 hours.
If they got all burned,
you can pick any one of your classmates
and you got 10 percent of their earnings
for the rest of their lives.
I asked you what goes through your mind
in determining which one of those you
would pick.
You can't pick the one with the richest
father.
That doesn't count.
I mean,
you've got to,
got to do this on merit,
but you probably wouldn't pick the
person that gets the highest grades in
the class.
I mean,
there's nothing wrong with getting the
highest grades in the class,
but that,
that isn't going to be the quality that,
that sets apart a big winner from the
rest of the pack.
Uh,
think about who you would pick and why.
And I think you'll find when you get
through,
you'll pick some individual.
You've all got the ability,
you wouldn't be here otherwise.
You've got the energy.
I mean,
you've got,
you know,
the,
the initiative is here,
the intelligence is here,
but some of you are going to be bigger
winners than others.
And it gets down to a bunch of qualities
that,
uh,
interestingly enough,
our self made.
I mean,
it's not how tall you are is not where
he can kick a football,
60 yards.
It's not whether you could run the
hundred yard dash 10 seconds,
whether the best looking person in the
room.
It's a whole bunch of qualities that
really come out of Ben Franklin or the
boy scout coater,
so whatever it may be,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's integrity is honesty,
it's generosity,
it's being willing to do more than your
share.
It's,
it's just all those qualities that are
self selected and then if you look on
the other side of the ledger,
because there's always a catch to these
free gifts and Jeannie jokes.
So you'll also have to,
and this is the fun part,
you also have to sell short one of the
your classmates and pay 10 percent of
what they do.
So who do you think is going to do the
worst in the class?
This is way more fun and think about it
again and again it isn't.
It isn't the person with the lowest
grades or anything.
Anything of the sort.
It's the person who just doesn't shape
up in the character department.
We look for three things when we hire
people,
we look for intelligence,
we look for in,
for initiative or energy,
and we look for integrity and if they
don't have the ladder,
the first tool will kill you because if
you're going to get somebody without
integrity,
you want them lazy and dumb.
You don't want them to.
You don't want a smart and energetic.
So,
uh,
is that third quality.
But everything about that quality is
your choice.
You know,
you,
you can't change the way you were wired
much,
but you can change a lot of what you do
with that wiring.
When you write down the qualities of
that person that you'd like to buy to 10
percent of.
Look at that list and ask yourself,
is there anything on that list?
I couldn't do the answers.
There aren't.
There won't be.
And when you look at the person,
you're so short and you look at those
qualities that you don't like,
if you see any of those in yourself,
you or whatever it may be,
selfishness,
you can get rid of that.
I mean,
that is not ordained.
And uh,
if you follow that,
you and Ben Franklin did this and my old
boss Ben Graham did this at early ages
and their young teens,
they just been granted looked around and
he said,
who do I admire,
you know?
And he wanted to be admired himself.
And he said,
you know,
why do I buy these other people?
And he said,
if I admire them for these reasons,
maybe other people would hire me if I
behave in a similar matter.
And he had,
he decided what kind of a person he
wanted to be.
And if you follow that at the end,
you'll be the person you want to buy 10
percent of.
I mean,
that's the goal at the end.
And it's,
it's something that's achievable by,
by everybody in this room.
Learning to tell a story is critically
important because that's how the money
works.
The money flows as a function of the
stories.
And what are the critical things I would
encourage you to learn that's way more
important,
important in my world and anything else
is how to ask a question because you
want to have the person comfortably
telling you what he thinks is important
so that you get for a long time.
We don't understand the product or the
market well.
We're listening so we have learned to
string questions in a way that provides
the entrepreneur with a way to explain
what he wants to do,
how long it's going to take,
who the competition is,
how much money he needs,
without feeling threatening for many of
the investments we've made.
We didn't understand the answers,
but we constantly work on developing the
questions.